forward i have to ask you about this
embarrassing meeting between
biden officials and the chinese
delegation we all remember your first
meeting
with the chinese officials including
president xi but
china ends up delivering this major
rebuke
to the united states to our faces
essentially saying that we have no
standing to lecture them because of our
own issues of racism that have been
perpetually parroted by democrats did
the chinese
ever lecture you or your people
about america's racism problem
we never had anything like that happen
that was an embarrassment
that was an absolute embarrassment to
our country
i have i could not believe it i couldn't
believe
the meeting even the location so many
different elements of
what took place uh when they started
uh and they went on and on and on you
know they were supposed to have a very
short period of time they went on and
uh it was terrible we should have walked
out
nobody ever talked to my group that way
nobody ever talked to me that way i can
tell you that
and uh if they did i would have doubled
up the tariffs which frankly were
something we probably should have done
anyway but we took
in i took in billions and billions of
dollars from china
we were bringing businesses back it was
really going well
and china respected us they never spoke
to us the way they spoke with this
administration
i'm sorry to interrupt but would you
have had mnuchin your treasury secretary
and your trade rep bob lighthizer
would you have instructed them to walk
out of that meeting if on americans
you were talked to like that they
wouldn't have even had to be instructed
but
if they didn't walk out they would have
been so instructed absolutely they would
have left
immediately mr president twitter
facebook youtube you know so many
conservatives
complaining about big tech censorship
and especially against you
you may have an unlikely albeit late
ally in this fight take a look
if you're asking me do i feel
particularly comfortable that the
president
the then president of the united states
could not express his views on twitter i
don't feel comfortable about that
there are reports that you're going to
go start your own social media company
is that how you plan to fight back
against these tech
oligarchs well in my case i have a lot
of options because
we have 200 million plus followers we
had 36 million just on potus
we had 90 million on the different
lines we had we're tremendously big on
facebook so we're
way over 200 million and i have a lot of
options but what i'm doing now i
almost like it better i think i do like
it better i'm getting to a point where
does
we're issuing press releases we're no
longer constrained by
a certain number of characters we're no
longer uh
put under you know the magnifying glass
and frankly you do it less and you can
do it better so
i put out statements now from the office
of
and the statements are picked up by
everybody i mean it it actually
works better now with that being said we
may
open up our own platform but the putting
out of statements putting out almost you
could call them a press release
when i have something to say to talk to
a lot of people
it gets to everybody it gets everybody
on twitter it gets everybody on
facebook it gets to everybody it's been
very effective
do you feel like you have a lot more
time on your hands without being on
twitter so much i mean
when i stopped yeah you do
actually i do it's very true and i don't
have to be so careful with
every word you know if i put a comma in
the wrong place it becomes like
he doesn't know proper english you have
no idea it's
you have much more time and actually
you you can really steer something and
focus something
on what's very important it really is
very good
and uh you know twitter has become very
boring i don't know if you know a lot of
people are leaving twitter it's become
very very boring
and i've heard it from so many different
people so we're off and a lot of other
people are off and a lot of people are
just
leaving it's become a very boring deal
i have a friend who recently saw you and
said that
he had never he had never seen you as
relaxed
and you were actually having fun and not
that you weren't having fun at the white
house
but you were having fun and you were
laughing so what is it like
just what is it like being out of the
white house obviously you prefer to be
in the white house but just
personally how is the decompression
going
well i'm enjoying it and i'm still
working very hard in so many different
ways but
you know i must tell you i am enjoying
it but what i really enjoy is doing good
things for this country
and we were doing things like nobody's
done i don't think anybody's done the
kind of
if you look at what we accomplished with
the largest tax cuts in history largest
regulation
cuts in history that's why we created
this great base in this great foundation
where our country came back so much
stronger you know they used to say
germany and all these other countries in
europe
well you look at them they're all locked
down they're shut down and
the virus is hitting them hard and the
vaccine isn't doing
well they're not getting now you know we
came up with a vaccine that was done
with my administration and frankly me
the fda is not in love with me because i
pushed them at a level that they've
never been pushed
but we got a vaccine in nine months
laura and it was supposed to take five
years fauci said
it's probably never gonna happen i mean
fauci was saying
three years four years five years a lot
of people said 12 years
and i got it done in nine months and
it's uh
you know it's really a great
accomplishment very
speaking of fouchy do you regret giving
him so much power early on
now look i got along with him fine but i
didn't listen to him too much
because he said don't close it up to
china and i did
very early don't close it up to europe
you know we had the problem with italy
and france
i did i closed it up to europe very very
early
uh he said uh don't wear a mess mass
don't work
no good no good i mean you know think of
what you look at his
the way i look at it you saw him throw
out the first pitch
in washington right he is a better
pitcher than he is
at what he does but he's a great
promoter but i got along with him it was
right
but if you really look i didn't really
listen to him too much because i was
doing the opposite of what he was saying
but i mean frankly if he were known as
somebody that was with me all the way
he wouldn't be popular with the media
he's just a media creation
and finally i want to move on um final
question
about biden's plans for the future watch
have you decided whether you are going
to run for re-election in 2024 you
haven't set up a re-election campaign
yet as your predecessor had by this time
my predecessor need to need it to
my predecessor oh god i miss him
um no an answer is yes my plan is to run
for reelection that's my expectation
your thoughts on what bind would look
like running again in
a few years well i think it's a great
question for him
that's just like all the other questions
they were all softballs and that's a
really
nice question because you're sort of
forgetting everything that's taken place
over the last uh
number of weeks and number of months and
you see what i see and
everybody sees it and the press doesn't
report it
and they understand it just as well as
we do it's uh
it's a crazy life we're leading right
now but that's okay
have you ever fallen over but they can't
they can't be allowed to destroy our
country
and at the southern border they're
destroying our country and gasoline
prices are going up
we are energy independent i created that
we have never been
energy independent we are now energy
independent but in another couple of
months we won't be and take a look at
what's happening to the price of
gasoline
it's up over a dollar that's like a big
tax increase to people
that's the same thing equivalent and
even greater than a big tax increase
it's
terrible what's happening is terrible
well i just
i just thought of one other thing a dear
fr another dear friend of mine
asked me to ask you this because he
happens to be
uh of color okay that's how he described
of color
and he said i've never seen a republican
work harder
i'm paraphrasing for minority votes as
this
prior president did referring to you and
yet they trash him and they call and
they left
racist he's racist he's racist how does
that personally
feel to you given the fact that you did
better among
minority voters in this last election
than anyone ever predicted
and i believe record setting yet they
continued to do that why did they do
that and how personally
does that feel to you so i did criminal
justice reform which obama and biden
could not get done they failed
miserably i did opportunities zones and
i created the best unemployment numbers
in the hist in
our history for african-american workers
and also for hispanic and asian and
everybody else and women
everybody but i created the best numbers
in history
and i did do i did fantastically well
with hispanic as you know i did
great with with african-american we did
great with asian
we did great but uh they used that they
used the race card
all the time not just with me anytime
they can't answer a question
they throw out the race card that's the
way it's been and frankly laura you know
better than anybody
the way it's been for a long time when
they can't get you on something
they throw out the race card but it's a
different world right now and we did
things that nobody thought could be done
you know criminal justice reform was a
very very big thing
and i guess biden tried i know obama
tried
they couldn't get anywhere i got it done
mr president thank you so much for
spending time with our audience tonight
i really appreciate it
thank you very much laura thank you